Comcast 41 seconds of logos and even
though some of them are adorably sung
acapella that's still 41 seconds of
logos
damn I think I'd be ticking off a sin so
early especially from this movie but
when my imaginary girlfriend starts off
by singing an incredibly sexy pop song
well you know about the power Hailee
Steinfeld goes from the front row to the
back row and a single edit so I'm
calling shenanigans she's talented and
pretty but she ain't Nightcrawler the
winningest acapella group of all time
Michael Moore would label this as
documentary filmmaking
the Barden Bellas an unlikely group of
not men who somehow managed to win at
something that didn't have to do with
bacon
haha movie we get to the John Michael
Higgins character is sexist it was funny
in movie one it was overbearing movie -
a movie three it makes me want to reach
through the screen and yank him out of
the frame also why is this documentary
already in black and white I finally did
it you go back together with Jesse no
you know the long-distance thing didn't
work miles away with his girlfriend
expositional misunderstanding you know
you got a tattoo of me on his butt cheek
so now every time he wants to see me
he's a stupid joke relies on the
audience conveniently forgetting mirrors
exist ellos reunion at the Brooklyn
aquarium hello that's tonight goddamn
there's a lot of exposition that comes
out of knowledge that all these assholes
should already possess her own fish cost
me my faith in drones and my faith in
fish awesome the substitution of pitches
for bitches has officially become as
tiresome and annoying as preface in
everything with acha acha scuse me
somehow all the girls have the same
hallucinatory montage about their jobs
and it's apparently filmed by the people
that did the office they're so bright
and shiny they look like they was all
breasted what does that even mean like
what does that even mean wait Lilly was
just shown to be a seamstress in the my
life sucks montage but she's also a
bartender isn't that a better entry for
the my life sucks montage and the
pitch-perfect franchise relies on gross
body humor even more than a fucking
illumination movie is there a
competition there should always be a
competition it's rare that you can
actually see the script being written in
real time during the movie can you fly
one you're eight months pregnant
I don't know Kenya pound whiskey when
you're eight months pregnant like you've
been doing tonight
was I not always in yeah but Emily
literally just akka block the Bellas a
few minutes ago in the performance why
is everyone so eager to include her did
they recognize her raw talent and true
grit also where the hell are the
documentarians during this entire Barden
Bellas reunion even if they're a public
nuisance they'd find some way to get
into the party right they're allowed to
go on the fucking USO tour wait are we
saying that Lily is a literal alien now
because I'm pretty sure that's racist no
a movie it does not automatically make
you cool to have a slow-motion shot of
all your characters walking together
my name is Chicago they also call me a
discount Marc Lucas will we be getting a
second base with you guys and then maybe
a few days later we'll go to the third
base man compared to this third movie of
a trilogy Fifty Shades freed had
tremendous sexual nuance make America
eat again that's a pretty lazy Trump
joke but more offensive is that these
movies and this actress and all the
other actresses are totally cool with
pointing and calling this girl fat over
and over again in this franchise just
for cheap laughs our presence here has
nothing to do with the nationally
televised salute to the Troops special
we're DJ Khaled is going to pick one
group to open for him at the end of this
tour that was a lot of exposition movie
pick a lane
are you self-aware and subversive or
just a fucking excuse for the whole
production team to hang out in Europe
you guys are seeing other people's songs
right like a cover band I'd like to see
you talk to Marilyn Manson like that no
seriously I'd like to see that
fazt Amy's overindulgence on hanging on
to this final note is a pitch perfect
metaphor for this franchise artists
didn't know a Jewish super racist like
so racist I'm not surprised that's in
this movie but I am surprised it didn't
come from one of the super racist
acapella television commentators this
fully instrumental band is able to pull
off a perfect a cappella rendition of a
cover song at a moment's notice
seriously this in hangar acapella battle
is less believable than the twilight
baby so even during soundcheck they're
all still doing the battle I never
thought I'd find a franchise that made
me long for the Transformers again but
here we are in hating this lazy third
entry into a franchise that has let to
be honest always been at least 20% lazy
wholly for a group of people that were
immediately derisive about the Bellas
doing covers these assholes know a lot
of covers
how'd they even all hear her ass over
the speakers and amplifiers their
current is blasting through fellas are
doing what they do best quitting was one
of the funniest science stories in the
first movie has quickly become its most
annoying yes we definitely needed three
goddamn cuts during the footage of the
van going down an extremely short street
Oh John let's go
what Despres pictures do they have a
view to force me to be part of this
movie you were supposed to be the chosen
one I mean I know the government doesn't
technically pay for USO shows but is
this expensive resort in the heart of
Spain really the best use of whatever
funds it I joined the National Guard
they helped put me through college
this goes on for some time so we've
never competed against bands that play
actual instruments what's the plan what
the first concern makes sense you've
definitely haven't ever competed against
bands with instruments before but why
would you then think that that means you
need a plan what plan what you got
invited here to do you do you how could
using our voices and no instruments
change in any way to be better suited
for battle against instruments time to
drop a smash hey remember when I send
the movie for being too reliant on
scatological humor earlier let me
revisit that get that bull 10 additional
cents
[Music]
leave it for this movie to mistake a
song about lovers parting for a song a
dad might sing while abandoning his
daughter
[Music]
we don't ever actually win and movie
cannot help undercutting itself with
what it thinks is clever dialogue sorry
I'm Thea strange looks like this movie
thinks it can't happen without Anna
Kendrick's character having a love
interest also jean jackets jeez it's
more random hookups in this USO tour
than the entirety of the Olympic Village
I know these films aren't known for
filmmaking technique but they just cut
from the three girls on stage being this
close to them being all far apart
granted I haven't gone and will never go
to a DJ Khaled concert but is this
really the type of band that's ever
gonna open for him put your hands
together for the Bellas I know this is
supposed to increase the tension because
the Bellas have to follow ever moist but
seriously who designed the show would an
acapella group even a great one ever
closed the show after a loud-ass rock
band and an energetic hip-hop duo lost
in a sea of semen in laziest version in
this joke you can make goddamn movie
okay military GA jonah Jameson even
blond her overly attached girlfriend
shailene Woodley's more evil cousin
Russian Tim Tebow disappointed head down
Rob Reiner praise and worship Moby
squinting ROTC Mike Epps and half the
brunette girls in the entire world
honestly his singing ability or not this
mostly male military crowd should be
boner cheering this all hot female group
of singers just on sheer hormones alone
rivals are laughing because they know
she's about to earn a 15-yard penalty
for Rost appropriation what was that
that my friend was taps from the back of
the house defeat the USO cut a goddamn
show off with taps is there any reason
for this happening these movies keep
suggesting that large groups of girls
and jammies are always hanging out
together in one single room and I
couldn't find any evidence of this
during my extensive research in college
should we be considering using
instruments do any of you even play
instruments also no you should not okay
buddy but these movies ever claimed to
be empowering of women but thank God
they didn't write wholly this movie
might actually set a record for slow-mo
walking montages I think the previous
standard-bearer was the entirety of
Entourage
and after all that most of these gals
dressed more Prommy than slutty look
whatever dj khaled is probably way too
wasted right now to even care what you
hem on
Oh psycho okay fun group goes to Europe
gets wrapped up in spy stuff there's an
older white actor who often stars in
Christopher Nolan films
this is Cars two all over again the c-4
explosives I found in the cereal box or
what about the time you smuggle drugs
and sir bounce-a-lot you said goodbye to
her it way too young an age for her to
remember all this kind of detail about
wine and go unknown where you've been
for years I don't think John Lithgow's
even trying to hide the phone that's
transmitting his performance
this works last we saw them the Bellas
were going to follow a guy they thought
was friends with Calot but they're
getting off this elevator alone so he
got on and went somewhere then they
followed him by getting on later and
it's ultimately the penthouse and DJ
Khaled sweet they literally stepped off
the elevator into Khaled suite which
means they definitely needed a keycard
they never could have ma'am can you
explain this terrifying situation haha
clever editing movie but it's clear that
Anna Kendrick was saying this to the
director
oh that an AKG C 24 yep a $14,000
microphone just hanging out in a
temporary rented hotel suite in Spain
for dj khaled to use in case he of the
one or two chart-topping singles comes
up with an idea on the road no one will
be seated during the scene where this
new love interest guy learns what
everyone who saw the first two movies
knows that Becca's a good DJ so excited
to see your show it's just too bad that
it can't make it cool what's that
Aubree's daddy issues onto the pile of
plot lines I could give a fuck about you
know how I'm always talking about how
dangerous it is to candle the end of a
room this is what checkmate checkmate as
if we didn't have enough information to
dislike her calamity walks in on a
catastrophe and immediately recognizes
it's the Bellas fault why did she
actually surmise this from the scene or
she just reflexively blaming the Bellas
[Music]
boobie has time for this I'm sure I've
been introduced to this character before
over the course of three movies but all
I know of her is that she's
inappropriately smiling during this
entire scene and that it's distractingly
annoying they were just at each other's
throats but a conveniently time baby
news phone call is going to instantly
turn things around into a love party
just like real life you guys thought the
Patriots had a big pep talk during
halftime of Super Bowl 51 no baby news
phone call you guys thought those German
and American soldiers put down their
guns for one night and sang songs
because of the spirit of Christmas
no baby news phone call they have
different military themed costume
changes how long was that montage of the
girls packing because it didn't seem
like long enough to tailor all this
perfectly
it's been three years since they've sung
together and we've never seen them
rehearse but they've got an entire
catalogue that they can execute
flawlessly where are these assholes
during the DJ Khaled party
god it's like Elizabeth Banks and John
Michael Higgins we're out drinking
around the Mediterranean for most of
this shoot and showed up whenever they
briefly sobered up you might think this
montage is meant to show the passage of
time and how the Bellas turn things
around for multiple ensuing dates in the
USO tour you might think this montage is
meant to show you DJ Khaled's gatekeeper
guy losing interest in calamity while
falling for Anna Kendrick you could even
be forgiven for thinking the montage is
meant to throw a bone to the costume
department that worked very hard on all
these concert show outfits but in
reality it's just padding time just like
the bonk of the sin sure they've been
featured in this montage but when the
hell did kal lads start paying attention
to the Bellas they trashed his suite at
the hotel and he was always checking his
phone when they were around before like
newbies seriously gonna yachty out of
this entire development welcome to the
South of France we want to do something
kind of special for you guys you know
like taking you to the city known as the
South of France also money is no object
and the troops are doing just fine
eating their MREs my dad was supposed to
come to see us perform tomorrow and I
heard that he can't make it holy crap
this is way beyond melodrama
this is the kind of thing a child gets
really sad about here now the female
lead and the guy crushing on her will
somehow accidentally bump into each
other at a pool because a child really
did write this movie that God how
beautiful apparently it's not beautiful
enough for Kayla to break from policy
back up DJ Khaled really seems like
Khaled just forgot his line here and
just went with the default of saying his
own name also he wants her to open up
for him not the Bellas just her there
was literally a Brady Bunch episode that
goes like this
these ain't opinions these are facts and
if I yell them loud enough at you you
will believe my bull is a tough decision
I get no it's not it is feel splinting
you can go wherever you want to go the
gap Bass Pro Shop guys if Callie picks
us it'll be our last show together and
if he doesn't pick you I am inside of
all of you hey remember when I send the
movie for over using the awkward
statement from a character awkward
reactions from the rest of the cast then
a beat of silence crush earlier I didn't
oh well here's 10 cents for it dude how
does fat daddy keep getting at all these
hotel rooms it's not like he can hand
out bribes and he just said that his
accounts were frozen you'll have
minutes come to the boat or your friends
swim with the fishes
why is Fergus just doing this now that
Amy's had access to her Cayman account
all this time so he could have shaken
her down at any time while she was in
the States maybe he couldn't get into
the US because of his legal troubles but
would it be too much to ask the movie
that has time for 2315 musical montages
to add this tiny detail I know my father
I know he's guys some of them I know
like really well this movie went out of
its way to suggest her dad left when she
was a very little girl making this part
here super dark went here before in here
the whole time I'm just small me Fergus
is a criminal but he's not an idiot
these movies are far-fetched for sure
but until now they didn't turn into a
Looney Tunes episode the fact that this
rescue plan somehow calls on Beca
stowing aboard as a sudden hostage then
convincing the girls to sing a song is
pretty ridiculous but even worse is that
Fergus just goes
let them sing like he's goddamn Marko
Ramius for this franchise I guess you
could replace the term jump the shark
with fat Amy kicks the got a three grown
man nice revisionist history movie but
this fight goes on way longer than the
song at the beginning which supposedly
shows the exact same sequence of events
fat Amy basically auditioning here for
the gender swapped under siege reboot
yes guy only just now is something amiss
you moron pitch perfect 3 a good day to
pitch art damn they were literally a few
hundred yards out into a bay that's all
but it took them from the dead of night
to bright ass morning to rescue them
Jesus job opening am i right if only I
could believe you it's time for us to
move on or they could keep singing right
I mean just because they didn't win this
stupid competition doesn't mean they
have to stop doing the one thing they
really enjoy doing together Jesus they
could sing at state fairs or jamberries
or literally anywhere you crush it okay
you crush it so hard that your nips
tingle a bit coming to you from the
Citadel who are they talking to here
like is this for the documentary if so
why don't they have the camera pointed
at them damn it movie this isn't
dodgeball or best-in-show or basketball
or the Phantom Menace or any of the
other movies he stole this trope from in
the first place
[Applause]
not only is this audio impossible given
that there's only one mic on stage but
it's also a giant due to DJ Khaled down
normally I support a giant due to the
less talented version of pitbull but
this makes no sense in the context of
the movie
this is calamities everything's ok now
even though I've hated these bitches all
movie and I didn't win this competition
that dominated my life in the last few
weeks because they're singing at be
cover of George Michael face hang on
Beca didn't even agree to the show until
like this morning how the hell do they
organized this entire set up also you
can't see me right now because narrating
is an audio medium but I'm getting this
movie at double birds salute with my
toes always give a hundred percent
unless you're donating blood
Aubree's dad shows up at the one
performance that the Bellas were
explicitly not going to perform until
the impromptu invite on stage great
everyone's getting laid tonight glad we
cleared that up before finally allowing
this series to mercifully die it is dead
isn't it they definitely had way more
fun making this than you did watching it
time to drop a smash ordinarily which
man the next two hours questioning your
sexuality running down your hometowns
and telling you to drop and give me
various numbers like do you really love
the lamp or you're just saying it
because you saw it I love lamp
we're hot chicks Double Down
white gotten 11 you always double down
on left I am inside of all of you who
took me by surprise